what if being an underdog or being the
black sheep of your family is actually
your gift the only thing standing
between you and the level of success you
want is the story you tell yourself on
why you can't get there self education
the new norm guys if you don't know Dean
let me do the intro again so we got cut
off this man is a legend entrepreneur
investor success coach multiple time New
York Times bestselling author we did the
top ten on him that got a lot of
positive feedback and it's it's it's an
honor having you on man thank you for
making the time it's I love seeing what
you're doing man it takes it takes a
whole you know village to raise a family
it takes everybody pushing what an
entrepreneur should be how we should be
and the path to get there quicker you
know so it's really incredible what
you're doing so I love it love to be
here appreciate that man
one of the things that that I look to
you for is is success habits I mean it's
something that you talk a lot about it's
something you've been able to shift a
lot of people on my own is entrepreneurs
and want to be entrepreneurs what are
some of the may be the core success
habits that they're missing that they
need to do to reshape their life for the
next year yeah you know I thought about
that especially the best way to serve
everybody who's watching is taking the
time to spend time with us today watch
it live or watching it as a replay and I
think it's it's uh it's crazy I just in
two weeks ago I turned fifty right
so this Wow doing about 50 yes to things
crazy thing about 50 it's like you get
to look back I don't feel old at all I
got another strong fifty ahead of me
right but you look back and you see
things with different life like listen
you're already on that path and so many
people watching where knowledge and
information turns into wisdom after you
get your ass kicked after you have some
success failure you know you take it's
like a hard drive taking in all this
data and eventually it comes like the
gut feeling gets stronger and stronger
so I was doing a podcast or an interview
the other day with my buddy I don't know
if you know Trent Shelton really cool
dude and Trent asked me a questions like
what is your what was your biggest
obstacle and I know you asked me about
success habits but I think this will
serve your audience in a really big way
yeah because it really hit my heart he
said to me you know you went from
we all have a story right I went from I
didn't go past high school I had
dyslexia my parents were married nine
times each we didn't have money we never
and I was I felt in high school like
just the oddball like all my buddies
were going off to college and I was the
dumb one with dyslexia and like I just
felt you know my guidance counselor said
it was either college or go work in a
factory like there was there was no
middle path right
I'm not knocking College I just wasn't
my rough road right so I started
thinking he said me what was your
biggest experience and I have to say
that it was like it was like time
condensed that but it was like I saw all
these things just what I told you and
and if you're listening right now I'd
love for you to think about the things
that were so-called obstacles in your
life right it wasn't money was it no one
supported you you live in the wrong area
barn and born in the wrong time you know
someone sold your money your parents
made you go to college and do a certain
thing we all have those things right so
I started thinking it was like time
elapsed like it was like I thought of a
million things in one second and then it
hit my heart that what most people do
wrong and I did wrong in my 20s if you
asked me in my 20s and 30s what were my
biggest obstacles I would have mentioned
my dad little crazy like all these
things and I realized it had nothing to
do with any of that heaven this
successful people realized the only
obstacle is your perception of the
situation you're in hmm and I know that
you've heard that and maybe you're
listening right now and you've heard
that you know thoughts are things and
thought but I really want you to hear it
for the first time someone who's been I
started being entrepreneur at 17 years
old cutting firewood then I fix cars
then I did houses I became a millionaire
in my 20s not not by luck by just
perseverance right and and have gone on
to create 13 successful companies and
all that great stuff my brand broke a
billion dollars in sales last year so I
guess I have this evolution so while I'm
talking I'm not I just want you I'm not
just some guy that's spewing out I've
had the evolution I've had my ass kicked
I've made lots of money I lost my money
and I'm in this place and I look back
and I want you to all think about this
if you're an entrepreneur go into the
next level I want to tell you something
that hopefully you'll remember for the
rest of your life the only thing
standing between you and the level of
success you want is the story you tell
yourself on why you can't get there and
as simple as that sounds you've heard my
buddy talking
robbing safe but it just doesn't sink in
because then you know no gene your money
my family isn't my wife thinks I'm
freaking nuts trying to be an
entrepreneur my boss has got a thumb on
my head that's all reality but what I
say is go Google that go find all the
incredible people that compilations you
put together my buddy Richard Branson I
mean I got to spend two weeks with him
on his island one week a year for two
different years but Nick I had more crap
and wasn't that smart and had dyslexia
and quit ninth grade I got to spend some
time with John Paul DeJoria say makes
like just look for someone else with the
same story as you so you can call it
crap you can call it a lie and just
really change the story and when I look
back if I would have kept the story that
I didn't have money and poor me and I
wasn't that smart I'd still be
struggling I would be I was lucky enough
to change that story and then what I
want just share today is what if being
an underdog or being the black sheep of
your family is actually your gift what
if that's God the universe whatever you
believe in gone pay your success tax
this is your underdog story you could
say you know the underdogs have the
power of you can't I got told I can't
you probably did too if my whole life oh
you can't do that you don't have money
oh you can't get on TV oh you can't
write a book you're in special reading
oh you can't you can't and all that did
for me and I was just lucky is when they
told me I couldn't write a book now I'm
a multiple New York Times bestselling
author write my second book broke a
million copies
how many people can say that right and
yeah I just don't have dyslexia and I
write the way I talk and people like it
or they don't write so what I found out
is that you can take the underdog story
the power of you can't people don't see
a comment people underestimate you you
could take heartbreak from a
relationship or someone not having faith
in use that heartbreak to be your anchor
or use it as fuel so I'm just going to
encourage everybody today yeah I could
give you some of the best marketing
strategies I'll give you some great
habits but man if you don't have it
right between here and Evan you know
this better than anyone you'll just spin
your wheels you'll have envy see other
people getting ahead you'll see people
on Instagram and social media moving and
you don't know why you're working hard
you're dedicated because you got to
change this change that story and
everything changes and yeah that's
that's kind of the foundation that's it
I just it's more of a realization in my
life right now than
never before so I want to share that I
love it man and for people don't know
the story how did you make that shift
from that environment to say now I'm
gonna take control like I'm in control
now it's my life you know okay I think
through there wasn't a moment I'd love
to say there was this epiphany I was
laying on my back looking at stars this
magical moment came it wasn't I just I
watched my dad work really hard in a
collision shop he worked on cars every
single day and I watched my mom worked
three jobs they were separated I was
going back and forth my mom cut hair
cleaned houses and did miscellaneous
jobs both my parents haven't worked
their ass off worked hard so when I hear
people say got a hard work got a grind
that's a bunch of my parents worked
really hard and neither one I've never
made over 25 $30,000 a year right so I
think there was this shift of and I love
my parents but they were the ones giving
me a lot of guidance and it was just one
- that if I listened to them if I
listened to my cousin's if I listened to
my family all of not one of them have
the life that I want and then I found a
couple people in my town it was Joey
Noto and Dominic a few so it was the two
wealthiest people in my little town in
upstate New York and most everybody was
Italian and this looked down and they
had different habits they had different
thoughts when I'd stop and see them and
I tell about this project at 18 I'm
trying to take down trying to raise a
half a million bucks thinning out out
come on
oh that's cute Dean tried to go on tell
me your strategy maybe I'll put a little
money in hey did you try this like they
they didn't think my ideas were dumb
they didn't think me dreaming was bad
they thought it was it was empowering
and I'm like wow so these people think
that way and they're the only
millionaires I know in my town and my
family thinks this way and they work
their ass off and they're going nowhere
they're running on it on a hamster wheel
and running on a treadmill what if I
just start thinking like them what if I
start using habits like them and the
shift just happened and then I remember
thinking then the difference was by the
time I got on high school I'm never
thinking really you're never gonna see
me coming play down to me now like I
think I wrote that stupid quote you do
in your high school book is you might
not know me now but you will soon or
something stupid like that but I found a
way to make it my empowerment not my
anchor but most people don't I mean
think of think of people who go through
a bad relationship
you know guys jackass he cheats on his
woman treats are bad and all this
and she keeps that story or vice-versa
he keeps that story for so long and
they're never open to a new relationship
because men are bad or women are bad
right it's just the story it's not the
circumstance it's the story there's
amazing relationships out there it's the
same with business same with being an
entrepreneur how do you see the next 50
being different than the first um that's
a really good question I bet in my 20s
and 30s I probably I took on projects
and partners and I mean official
partners but working with people that
maybe weren't completely aligned with my
values but I thought it could move my
career and make me money and that got
less and less and now this next 50 just
an impossibility
I only partner only do things with
people that share my values who light me
up who make me want to be a better man
be a better you know father be a better
leader be a better everything so it's
it's come combining the mission like I
read a lot about you I've been watching
your videos for a long time and you have
a similar mission like I know the here
the hero you are for entrepreneurs
you're there you're a cheerleader you're
providing value and I want to make self
education the new norm and Tony Robbins
and I are launching a new product
April 25th I'll keep you posted but it's
really gonna make an impact of helping
people extract their wisdom track their
knowledge extract their expertise and
share it with other people I feel like
people if they die without sharing their
knowledge especially people who move the
needle in life it's like throwing away a
20 million dollar hard drive like you've
compiled all this great stuff failure
success this is how you break through
momentum personal growth you compile it
all and then you just go throw it away I
want to make it when people feel guilty
if they don't extract what they know and
share it with the world and now we have
social media it's such an easy way to
share it and in some cases monetize it
but more more so I want to I'd love to
change the global conversation on
education and make self self education
one of the new norms so that just that
pumps me up what I say tea I'm fired up
just thinking about I love man I love
when winds out launching April 25th nice
okay cool
I send me the link man I want in on a
sharing special we've been working on it
for about eight months and it's gonna be
something killer how about your YouTube
like what's your YouTube strategy none
terrible
we had so here's the thing we we you
know I've been in the infomercial
business for 20 years yeah
so 20 years of infomercials half of that
time I had the number one or number two
infomercial on the plants why Tony and I
became friends for a while him and I
were competing for the number one
infomercial right yeah so I really
ignored social media up until I mean a
year ago I had 18,000 people follow me
on Instagram I just started going doing
Facebook or Instagram stories every day
and now I think we're at 250,000 growing
like crazy cuz I'm putting the attention
in we I started putting a little tension
on Facebook and we're at 1.5 million
followers or likes on there but we
really just now are starting our YouTube
strategy so I think there's someone I
know it's pretty good at that so we
might hit you up right dude happy to you
like YouTube I think is such an easy win
for you it's great because it's a video
platform a new crush video like
obviously yeah and a member doing the
research for your top 10 was a little
challenging because there's always Clips
some different channels not your own but
the like Instagram is a hamster wheel
where if you stop your hosting content
you're done YouTube your content from
five years ago is still getting views
but in terms of leaving leaving a legacy
and making education happen it's just
such a natural fit yeah we're going to
do I have a great kid that's running my
YouTube ads which are doing unbelievable
but we want to get the generic you know
the the more you know the office not the
ad side but more generic side rockin and
we'd love your help on that yeah we can
connect after happy to men another one
of your your thoughts that I love that I
connect with is the manufacturing
confidence the idea that you can
manufacture confidence like talk us
through that how it works the benefits
what you do it's awesome some of the
things I'm gonna share you guys have all
heard but I'd love to just remind you to
pretend you're hearing it for the first
time I mean how many times have you
heard the people you surround yourself
as who you've become you do but you're
still hang out with your negative friend
who tells you you're crazy like we hear
this stuff and what happens is and I
want everybody to really listen to this
we all think yeah yeah that personal
growth stuff is good it makes me feel
fluffy but what's the real secret Dean
like I'll get with people and I'll tell
them stuff like maintaining your
confidence without confidence you can't
be successful yeah yeah but
you sell so hard on camera it's like
it's actually like yeah okay the first
time I thought about meeting a
millionaire some day like I honestly
when I was broken a kid I thought a
millionaire would be look around and
like open up this box and like sunlight
would shoot out though this is the
secret to wealth and they hand it to you
and it was exactly what we're talking
about today things like confidence all
the things that you share but then the
first time I went to Branson's Island
then it wasn't because I was cool is
because I raised a million dollars for
his charity Virgin Unite so he invited
me to hang out with him for a week
Necker so i flying in Decorah and i have
to be honest now he asked me to go sail
around the island with him and I'm
waiting for him to go well millionaires
is easy but a billionaire here's the
magic box right right and it's the same
and people still go yeah yeah yeah
that's cool I wanna be warm and fluffy
and jump up and down but what is it it's
this it's things that we're talking
about right now
for example confidence I mean confidence
to me is literally one of the most
important things for success because if
you think about it um think about it if
you have you ever got the girl got the
promotion got the sale did anything in
your life well when your confidence is
down right you play small you don't you
don't want to play you don't want to
engage you don't wanna ask the girl ask
the guy you don't want to ask for the
money don't want to close the deal you
don't want to really ask for the money
because maybe it's not that like nothing
works without confidence so to me you
got to protect your confidence at every
angle like we're like to me confidence
needs to have armor around it and
anything in your life that messes with
that confidence it has to go you have to
just get rid of it or eliminated I mean
silly stuff again you guys have heard
this but but you look at the news I
haven't watched the news in 12 years I
don't know if anybody you guys can
comment if you want has anybody watching
right now never watch the news and got
down you're like damn I feel amazing
let's go crush it like you watch the
news like ah you know our country is
going to hell in a handbasket
everything's named so for me something
like negative news something like
negative people in my life who tell me
that maybe you shouldn't go for that
you're a dreamer that's not really right
or you're wrong bad advice like all
those things to me
they ding my confidence
they have to go i it sounds terrible but
I push everybody out of my life that
Rob's my confidence I want to bring
confidence and and and reciprocity and
love to people but if I'm not getting
that in return they got to go same thing
with the news I will not watch if I'm at
the gym and the news on in from me I'll
find a new Stairmaster
because I don't want it to mess me so
that is Manufacturing confidence because
I'm I'm eliminating the things that gain
my confidence secondly what I love to do
is I love to borrow confidence from the
past because when you say manufacture if
I'm walking into a meeting like even
when the first time I met Tony I have to
be honest Tony was like if you would
have asked me 20 years ago if you could
meet anyone in the world that would've
been Tony Robbins I bought personal
power over 20 years ago and I was
already successful but it shifted my
life and I knew someday I wanted to meet
him and thank them and now we're
partners and you stage and launch this
business the other but the first time I
met Tony I was writing vomit on myself
and I'd already had a business doing 50
million 60 million dollars a year
actually a hundred million by the time I
met him but I still was nervous but I
manufactured my confidence and what I
did is looked backwards and I found
areas in my life where I was scared and
I still did it and I had a massive
massively positive outcome and I let
myself feel that like you were scared
you still went up on stage you did a
million in sales Wow and I'll just flood
myself with pastas that were scary and
the result going good and all of a
sudden I manufacture confidence in the
now robbing it from the past and if I'm
not letting the outside world get in I'm
already on the edge of confidence that
won't just usually bump me up to where I
need to be I love it and for people who
are watching news and watching Netflix
and binging on all that stuff and now
they decide I'm gonna cut it out what
what's the dean grass Eocene number one
replacement what am I going to replace
once I cut out the news and Netflix yeah
I listen I I need it's like going to the
gym like I think a lot of times some of
you'll binge on YouTube watch your
videos and other great ones for a
weekend and feel amazing on Monday and
then not look again for three weeks and
think they're gonna stay it's like it's
like we went to the gym today and we
worked out for nine hours right it
doesn't matter if we go back if we don't
go back for two months we're gonna we
lose it's the same thing so I binge on
personal growth every day I mean I work
out every morning I do an hour at least
ever
an hour every day of an audiobook I just
got done reading the culture code which
is an amazing book you know I I'm
obsessing I obsess on personal growth so
if I have a free moment I'm working on
things that either empower me or move
the needle in my life
that one other thing that's a it's a
habit that's simple but it's a part of
my DNA now is I'm always analyzing
things that are just energetic take time
and effort but don't move the needle and
the things that really can move my life
forward and I'm I have this I look
through this filter because sometimes
you don't realize you get this hypnotic
rhythm and you just do something do
something and then one day I'll go wow
that that shouldn't be on my to-do list
that has to be on a not to do list I
have to stop hanging with that person I
have to stop surfing online I just not
like and I just always put through this
filter it's just moving my life in the
direction I want or is it not and I just
throw away the knots and I try to fill
in more of the things that move the
needle so but personal growth still I
don't go two days without some kind of
personal growth dude it's crazy like
time flies when you're having fun right
yes no I love it like we're top live on
Instagram right now and across the
entire platform thank you everybody for
joining and watching Dean we've got you
know one minute left what's what's the
message that you want to put out there
just a couple things one you're good
enough you don't need anything more that
you have I've been blessed to meet so
many successful people and they're just
like you they're just people who didn't
give up persevere don't listen to the
wrong people and don't wait till 2019 to
set your goals set them today start
making moves today when everybody's at
the starting line January 1 you could be
going 60 miles an hour already I love it
and for people they want to find you you
got your YouTube channel about to come
out and crush it yeah besides that where
where do you want people to go are you
gonna Instagram follow me on instagram
and also my book dean's free book com if
you want to grab my newest book
millionaire success habits it just
passed 400,000 copies so it's on fire
awesome man awesome I appreciate it man
keep up the good work I mean that thanks
man you too and looking forward to doing
something else in the future it's coming
soon all right thanks Dean Cheers if you
want more dean grat COC check out the
top ten rules video I made on him the
link is right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there I
want to tell you passion and from the
heart always always wins over over
prepared and thinking from the head